godzilla vs kong isn't the only time you
will see the big g
in action this year toho has announced
and even released trailers for its
upcoming series called godzilla singular
point
so yes there will be two godzilla 2021s
and which one is the better looking one
of the two it's up to you to decide as
the preferences are subjective
beauty lies in the eye of the beholder
except for kong kong would not like
legendary godzilla at all
he punched him and said your face looks
ugly bro nah i'm just kidding
both of these godzilla's look good and
we will do a full comparison of the
designs of legendary godzilla 2021
and toho godzilla at singular point 2021
so let's do this thing let us start with
the head
legendary godzilla from godzilla vs kong
retains a similar head design
as to 2019 and 2014 with a few changes
that are minor and hardly noticeable
the face is blocky its neck is broad and
has
shock like gills making it the first
godzilla design to 2014
to feature gills his eyes are small with
a golden yellow color
and his teeth are small and not nearly
as straightly lined up as in previous
godzilla designs
the nostrils are more separate being on
opposite sides of the snout
singular point godzilla has a stubbier
face with bigger eyes
situated more on the top of the face the
most distinctive feature are the
saber-tooths that jut
down from the upper jaw the teeth are
overall
bigger in relative to the wolf slash
crocodilian snout of godzilla singular
point
now let's see the body the body of
legendary 2021 godzilla is similar to
the 2014
design and also the 2019 in which his
belly is bigger
as the 2014 version but also has a very
defined and muscular
chest like the 2019 kotm version his
scales are similar
as the earlier versions as they are
small and overlapping ones
the only differences are that he has a
rougher and spicy texture around his
entire torso
singular point godzilla brings a very
distinctive design for godzilla
in that in this version he seems to look
more dinosaurian in appearance
he has sharp scales around his neck and
back as well as
a loose flappy scale-like texture that
overlaps one another in
rows along his upper thigh and arms
godzilla versus godzilla has the same
thick ties as the earlier versions
and his arms are smaller in relative to
his body but it's not really a
disadvantage
or a big deal as we can see him being
able to bit slap kong into oblivion
godzilla's claws are black in color and
his feet are wider and resemble an
elephant
foot more or less than the other
godzilla's feet do
the feet are then altered in 2019 and
2021 which is now
to more closely resemble those of past
designs
with larger curved claws and each toe
set more apart from the other
godzilla's singular point however has
more defined elbows
and might i say curvier legs the design
is made to closely resemble dinosaurs
and the claws of this godzilla feet are
very big and there are three toes
with an extra small one above the heel
the limbs make this version of the g-man
look more animalistic and primal in
nature
now let's go up and look at the dorsal
plates
while legendary godzilla's dorsal plates
were originally straight and sharp
his battle with demuto prime enabled his
broken place to regrow and have a more
distinctive maple like shape instead of
being jagged and straighter in design
the new design features more protrusions
and the three large central dorsal
plates running from the midway down his
back
are the same shape as the original
godzilla's dorsal blades
singular point godzilla's dorsal plates
however are one of my favorite designs
to be honest
first of all they have a different
coloration in contrast with the body
that is black
the plates are whitish in color with red
vines that run in between them
and makes them look like a leaf they are
also present in more numbers and arrange
in more rows than legendaries
godzilla's tale is considerably longer
than most designs
i mean that of the master verse and
becomes very thin and pointed at the end
in godzilla king of the monsters his
tail is proportionally shorter compared
to the rest of his body
although it is still longer than before
and ends with a rounded tip
godzilla 2021 has the same tail type as
the 2019 version
and in fact it looks to be more flexible
as it can accurately destroy jet
fighters in mid air
singular point godzilla also has a very
long and thick tail
it is seen to be very flexible as it can
be looped around itself
it almost looks like it is prehensile
and it can grab things
there are small dozer plates that run
down and are present till the tip of the
tail
which is very sharp like extinct
dinosaur tales
now we come to the atomic breath the
most of us godzilla seems to use it as a
weapon of last resort
rather than his primary weapon in his
battle with the mutos
but more frequently in his battles with
king ghidorah and now it's gone
when godzilla charges his atomic breath
he draws energy from his bionuclear
circulatory system
this triggers a neutron flux that
manifests as a blue glow
which slowly moves from the tip of the
tail up his protective
dorsal plates and finally the energy
reaches godzilla's throat chambers
where it then explodes into a
concentrated wave of atomic energy
single point godzilla has yet to reveal
his atomic breath
as the series is yet to be released on
netflix
but as the trailer shows he will be able
to charge up before he shoots it
and the flame would most likely be white
in color
with a tint of blue now we come to the
most interesting comparison
size most of us godzilla was originally
introduced as a 355 ft tall titan
with a 550 feet long tail and weighing
90 000 tons this changed in godzilla
kotm
king of the monsters with the titan
growing up to
393 feet tall or almost 120 meters in
height
and with a tail length of 582 feet
or 177 meters and a weight that is only
336 tons
shy of a hundred thousand the second
heaviest next to godzilla earth
singular point godzilla has not been
released as yet
and so has its statistics but is
suspected to be smaller than both
shin and legendary godzilla's behavior
is that of territorial animal
a monster versus godzilla that is ishiro
sarizawa theorized that godzilla
is the driving force to restore balance
to nature whenever that balance is
disrupted
suggesting that he is essentially the
ruler of earth and he considers the
entire earth to be his territory
in godzilla's singular point however the
story would depict
a couple of young geniuses mei kamino
who is a female researcher and
yoon arikawa who is a male engineer as
they take on an unprecedented threat
with their companions it might be that
godzilla in this universe
would be the main threat against
humanity going back to his roots as does
destruction
incarnate which is quite opposite to
most of us godzilla as he is a protector
anyway what do you think about this
video on the comparison of legendary
godzilla 2021 from
godzilla vs kong and that one from toho
slash netflix
godzilla's singular point if you have
noticed something more then do put them
down in the comments section
okay these are the two godzillas from
2021 that we will be seeing in the next
two months
yeah this year will be the year of the
kaiju so subscribe if you haven't
smash that subscribe button to be a part
of the minecube family
and slap slap slap that notification
bell for regular updates
on new video releases till the next
video
take care fam